did we get here
my name is Tara chambers and this is
Tara Jessa we just saw the greatest show
the greatest show the ironically named
greatness
I think we all went into this with the
most part it kind of met those
expectations it's not only met exceeded
it like blew our love expectations out
of the water so we thought could go this
low and went so much lower but it was so
passionate so ambitious I adored this
movie I've never seen so much effort in
production design choreography music the
singing all the talent stage go to
nothing
there is nothing and yet there is so
much talent behind it every time this
song sequence is on we keep it expected
like a coke logo to go by like super
courage every single song to me anyway
felt like either the opening song or the
closing song with the big inspirational
every single song I wanted to see either
the movies title or the end the end
reddit start rolling yeah and like also
we all know that PG barn was a piece of
crap and like that's like the main
controversy of the movie but
like I loved him I loved to this movie
is like going into Abraham Lincoln
vampire hunter is really fun vampire is
like everybody knows this isn't his life
this is just the minute it starts this
is like okay this is pure fantasy
romanticized bullshit like even after
school special somebody read this poorly
coming up next Hitler and love story
clearly this is just pure fabrication
but it is just so into it and tragically
misdirected but they're so inspiring Lee
misdirected I will say this the director
knows how to do music sequence can I
have their amazing the thing I hate
about bad musicals is like to me a movie
musical should have like this raw
kinetic energy use the camera should be
moving you should feel the dancing the
singing you should be like just
seriously freaking energized and I like
like the Phantom of the Opera movie that
we hate yeah there's like no energy no
energy the camera is always kind of
static and like but this one's like all
the songs were great about that energy
energetic dancing the singing even the
characters with like zero lines when
they had a moment to sing on camera yeah
you know that Harry man or whatever he's
just in the whole time just he has no
lies you just look at that they have
like what my is like up
[Laughter]
nobody is phoning this in everyone is
leaving a million percent but it's
tragically misdirected because like it
is amazing it's so much passion so much
energy you just feel it in every shot it
just goes into total crap yeah cuz the
story it comes through that PT Barnum
was this awful person he does something
douchey but then an inspirational listen
guys the song sequences they're so good
and they come it's counting Newsies
where it comes right the hell out of
nowhere like you see I see Newsies but
like it's one of those where it's like
you'll sit down with tech airframes just
talk about making the deals over what do
you say it's like well I think and we
you should have a drink we should take
this which is just like where did this
come from
if you want my honest opinion that's
what this movie most reminded me of was
Newsies yeah but the problem is fun
though yeah but yeah that's the weird
thing it's like Newsies is objectively
probably a better movie like there's a
plot there's a beginning of milind but
when it comes to entertainment value
this was so bad that it was kind of more
entertaining today Newsies which I
Jessica's bro yeah it was adding up you
could feel it like everything felt kind
of disjointed it was like something's
not it was complicated and he's in like
that era wasn't exactly kind to people
who are different to begin with but it
just so good like whatever like story
you could get out of PT Barnum bed that
showed you the dark side and maybe some
of his okay so like you get none of that
here
he's a dick and then the next second
it's disliked but let's see the
inspiring complexity like you're right
there could I'm sure there were good
aspects of him and like but you don't
see really anything you just see like he
was a dark character he exploited a lot
of people but I mean I don't think he
was pure evil either but you need to get
done like this movie in no way earns any
trust no there's no part of me that's
like I bet that happy wait we gotta make
this clear
there was he'll be else in this movie
theater it was just before flipping our
shit behind movies mst3k that probably
played a big part in us like you do
because we have to be quiet it might
have been tough yeah but because we
could talk through it and will happen
enjoy it I I had a ball I I would gladly
see this movie and not even like I'll
rent it so I mean it's what you think
it's gonna be and it's not at all no it
is what you think it's gonna be and so
much more so much more no no no like it
is awful but it is just it might be it's
so entertaining it is just insanely
entertaining I just had a blast watching
it and laughing at it but also enjoying
the energy and the enthusiasm like you
know this is probably like one of the
most passionate enthusiastic films like
I've ever seen so at the end of the
movie spoiler alert
I guess as if it man it's like you don't
know where this movie's going he learns
the the valuable family story about
family and so he goes and he he passes
on the the head and says you're the new
ringmaster that get brought in the
middle but show
you exploit these people I'm just gonna
get rich off do nothing really like
you're deciding this right now just goes
in and does 15 and then it's just like
i'ma go I'm gonna go see my family and
so he goes to his little kids ballet and
literally shows up on African elephants
just people yes / - yeah no he's already
late to this thing because he had to do
have a show and we were coming together
so he takes the fastest rubber
transportation New York City an elephant
just otterby a tree and there's an
elephant ear just gets off the elephant
leaves during this ballet outside
there's an elephant going on a freakin
rabbits down anyone saying like somebody
just gets up the speaker system with the
license plate X Y T Z butthole please
come out to control your animal and he's
just like flight I'd hate to be back by
the bearded lady for a very obviously
very expensive production what was that
dance that the singer was doing Oh the
what sir lady oh yeah this moment yeah
this woman's a signal sent this amazing
voice he apparently doesn't listen to
her until she goes on even there was
like months to get this going we were
jumping then she just gets on stage
yeah when she starts singing first of
all I think the beer lady said it better
she's literally doing the diva from the
fifth Alvin I think the disappointing
thing for me is that I honestly would
have thought that a movie about the
freaks as a musical would be an
interesting movie and it's really just
about Petey Barney adding them through
his life like leaving up every important
like it just breezes through everything
no nobody's fans rates of just the bare
basics of PT Barnum and it's literally
just like a quick it's like they're
showing him do these bad things and like
swindle people is nothing like he did
but then they're like painting him as
this victim and he's then so it's like
not you don't even really get to see him
work the entire movie is a metaphor for
PT Barnum if it was this is the star
crash of circus exploitation yes except
legitimately has money and a really
amazing production I guess I thought she
was good I don't see like many funny
like I said nobody was half a Singh this
at all it's just unbelievably misguided
series of circus related music videos
strung together with nothing yeah it's
like imagine all the greatest
ingredients in the world but like now
I'm gonna put them all in one dish and
you just get this brown man
these were all great if I can pick this
together have you too many ingredients
in breath of the wild it's the dubious
food yes you get something - yeah it'll
give you some parts but you also get a
very good well thank you so much for
watching your with me but you buy the
venue that is nothing how did you mean
it I meant it sincerely that was good
bro I really enjoy and I'm a dad
you